(hip hop music)
- And we're back.
Before we went to commercial break,
we left our friend Jordan here
making a very important decision.
He's going to decide what
barber gets his clippers.
Now back in my day, we
didn't get to decide.
You just got in the char,
and when you was in it,
you took whatever tools they had.
They had a knife and they
used it to shape you up--
- I've been coming to this
shop for quite some time now,
and I've been trying to decide
upon the different barbers.
This is one of the hardest things
I've ever had to do honestly because--
- Hey, yo.
Y'all want some CDs?
What, y'all shooting a show?
- Boy if you don't get out of here
with your CD rhymes and your dot coms.
Get the hell out.
- Wait, do you have the, nevermind.
- No, they're shooting a
show and we're doing it.
- Lamar.
- You give great cuts, excellent line ups,
some of the best I've ever
had in my entire life.
But honestly man I don't
appreciate how you be
recording the back of my head
and putting it on Instagram.
Yo, I don't fuck with that.
- That's the thing
where you take the video
and you put it on Twatter?
- I'm sorry, what?
- You take the video and
you put it on Twatter.
- On what?
- On Twatter!
- Yo, I use it like a
digital business card.
- No, it's not.
- Daniel, now you give me great advice.
You always know the right things to say.
But it takes you like
two hours to cut my hair
because you're always on that damn phone.
- Always on that phone.
- Yo, what's good?
- It was important.
- No, it wasn't.
Darryl.
Now your chair's in the
front of the shop, so nah.
- What?
- You ain't getting these clippers, man.
- Well, why not?
- You know why.
- But--
- Appreciate it
You are my far--
- Hey, what y'all want?
- Yo, can I get a Philly steak?
- [Order Taker] Yeah.
- Yeah, can I get the
turkey burger, no bacon.
- Mmm-hmm.
- Yo, let me get one
large chicken terryaki.
- Got it.
- Yeah, let me get a number seven.
You know what, I'm not
going to get nothing.
I don't want to do what I
did to the bathroom last week
when I did it, you know?
- Hey, yo, you want anything?
- No, I'm good.
- All right.
- You want my number two?
- No.
Jonathan, you are by far
one of the meanest people
that I've ever come in contact with.
In fact, you scare me sometimes.
Yo, you really be intimidating me.
- Because you a bitch.
- Well, thank you.
Now the person that I've decided
to give my clippers to is...
- Oh, sorry, wrong place.
- Guys. Guys, come on.
Guys, guys, come on.
- How you doing young tenderona,
let me talk to you a second.
- I'm about to give my clippers.
It was one of you three.
Guys! Guys!
Here.
- Thank you.
- Gotta get him to cut my hair.
Everyone want to leave for a girl.
I'm about to have a messed up hairline.
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
Go, go (crying).
(hip hop music)